[Música]
son gigantes de hielo que han ido
raspando lentamente las cumbres durante
miles de años
los glaciares como monumentos naturales
constantemente cuidados por hombres y
mujeres que observan su evolución diaria
y trabajan duro para protegerlos son los
guardianes de los glaciares
en los alpes lactoglass o mar de hielo
es el mayor glaciar de Francia
tiene fascinado desde hace 35 años al
glaciólogo Luke mogó
fue él quien instaló estos marcadores
para dar testimonio del deshielo de los
glaciares en 2018 la pasarela estaba
aquí y había una cueva justo aquí
el glaciar estaba justo aquí y se podía
entrar en la cueva desde el sendero
suspendido el paisaje actual no se
parece en nada al de antaño hace un
siglo se podía entrar directamente en el
glaciar desde el mirador de Montaner A
1900 metros de altura hoy en día los
200.000 turistas que visitan cada año el
mar de hielo no pueden evitar sentir
cierta decepción esperábamos algo así
pero cuando ves los niveles de hielo de
100 años atrás y de hace 50 años es
realmente inquietante no se parece mucho
a un mar de hielo más bien parece un mar
de rocas hoy en día para llegar al hielo
hay que bajar por esta larga escalera
hasta el túnel excavado en el glaciar
en este lugar el mar de hielo pierde más
de 8 metros de espesor cada año en uno o
dos años este trozo de roca estará en la
superficie el glaciar ya no se mueve se
derrite en el acto y como no se forma
más hielo la disminución de su tamaño se
acelera no se alimenta de hielo nuevo
cada año lo único que puede hacer el
glaciar es derretirse y retroceder no
lejos del mar de hielo otro glaciar
emblemático de los alpes franceses
también es víctima de un deshielo
acelerado
el glaciar de bosón hace en la cima del
Mont Blanc y se extiende a lo largo de 7
km
estos excursionistas tendrán que caminar
dos horas desde el valle de chamonix
para llegar al glaciar nuestro humilde
Guardián Cómo estás timote bien y tú
bonito día para visitar el glaciar
timotemo tan dirige el refugio en el
camino hacia el glaciar
en lugares ideal para observar los
cambios diarios del paisaje
tras el deshielo de las pirámides de
hielo que hicieron famoso abuso apareció
recientemente un lago
a medida que el glaciar retrocede
descubrimos cada día nuevas rocas nuevos
bloques nuevas losas nuevos lagos como
este es lo que lo hace tan interesante
el senderismo por el glaciar bosón
a medida que subimos el glaciar revela
otras sorpresas ya que los objetos que
ha transportado durante años en su hielo
reaparecen de repente en la superficie
esto es parte del tren de aterrizaje de
un Boeing estoy seguro de ello puede
ayudarme hay un número de serie Mira
está justo aquí
dos aviones se han estrellado cerca de
la cima del Mont Blanc en 1950 el
malabar Princess
y luego en 1966 otro avión de India el
Boeing chunga 5 décadas después sus
restos empezaron a reaparecer a 3.000
metros de profundidad Esta es una pieza
de la cabina con sus accesorios el avión
cayó cerca de la Cumbre del Bombón y
adaptado 50 años en llegar hasta aquí en
piezas de repuesto Por así decirlo
Gota a gota el glaciar revela reliquias
retrocede Y atestigua en silencio un
rápido y peligroso deshielo
las temperaturas suben y la montaña se
vuelve frágil en algunos lugares hasta
el punto de quebrarse
estamos cerca de la cima de Lady
alpinistas pero también científicos
ludovic graban Él y su colega estudian
las consecuencias del calentamiento
fijaremos un ancla en el borde para
bajar al espolón rocoso luego fijaremos
una cuerda de 100 metros y descenderemos
por ella parece que anochece nevó
trajiste la pala
nevó fuerte durante la noche los dos
hombres emprenden una peligrosa
exploración en un tipo de glaciar muy
diferente
el llamado glaciar colgante que se
aferra a la pared del acantilado
bajo la capa de nieve fresca deben
encontrar el sensor que mide las
temperaturas
una ardua búsqueda que finalmente da sus
frutos tras una hora de esfuerzo
finalmente encontramos el cable del
sensor
después de mover un par de docenas de
metros cúbicos de nieve
esperábamos encontrar a 16 metros de
profundidad donde el glaciar toca la
roca Una temperatura de -4 pero estamos
cerca del punto de fusión en donde estos
pequeños glaciares congelantes corren el
riesgo de desprenderse los guardianes de
los glaciares han dado la voz de alarma
nuestros glaciares son gigantes con pies
de barro y están especialmente
amenazados en los alpes aquí donde la
temperatura asciende dos veces más
rápido que a nivel del mar en todo el
planeta